think it's time to come together you and
i
can make a change that is tim mcgraw and
tyler hubbard with the anthem that we
all need right about now and i'm so
excited
because my fellas are joining me right
now tim and tyler how y'all doing
oh good how about you uh i'm good
because undivided has been on rotation
for me i wonder
um how this song came together like tim
how did you and tyler look up
to do this song well i let tyler start
because he wrote it and he sent it to me
i had covet i was in quarantine and so i
wrote a whole bunch of songs
tim and tyler's new song and music video
drops wednesday
and the title undivided is interesting
last fall fans speculated that tyler and
his florida georgia line bandmate brian
kelly were breaking up after tyler
stopped following bk on instagram
and both guys announced solo projects
just to clarify fgl's not breaking up
we've always done every single thing
together so it really does feel good
to say bk go make your solo project and
go have fun with it while in the
meantime still releasing our fifth album
in february and you know continuing the
tour in 2020 tyler and his wife welcomed
baby number three son
atlas and he gave us a sample of one of
his solo songs something he wrote for
three-year-old daughter
olivia thank god for little girl
my daddy
that's about you she's an entertainer
she loves music she loves entertaining
she loves to dance she loves
everything she always wants daddy watch
daddy watch which
reminds me of myself as a kid girl dad
tim is also spending some quality time
with his daughters hosting harry potter
and game of thrones themed dinners with
wife faith hill
anything to make my girls happy you know
we were all at the house and we were
trying to think of interesting things to
do to just have fun
yeah what's the next themed dinner i
don't know those they just about wore me
and
me and mom being faith out so i don't
know we're going to put some theme
betters off for a while
guys i thank you so much i do love the
song it really is needed
right now so we appreciate you thank you
guys so much